joining us here as the head coach of
that team and also a good friend from
the NFL Network and part on parcel of
SeatGeek here this Super Bowl week good
to see you Brian sir
yeah well that's an applause line
[Applause]
enthusiasm yet although he has been on
Match Game a round of applause for the
people here remember the match game Pass
is too young and honest no no no do you
remember what your what your your match
game Clue was you know what the blank
was that nobody for a mistake when you
say the match game they'd lot of time to
think of like the dating game this was
when they had the panel of six people up
there should give you a sentence and
leave and and leave it blank yeah right
gene you know he had the big microphone
[Laughter]
I did not get a single point you didn't
get a play a point yeah I mean the old
match game was you know old man
Belichick brought his team to the Super
Bowl and took on the Rams and went blank
you know and then he had to fill my
defense though yes it's the questions if
you hear the questions now and it's
great because my daughters were the
first time now there's not a promise you
yes
I don't go a month that someone doesn't
say you know here I I've accomplished a
few things you know I've won a Super
Bowl I've done a career for 40 years ago
I the match game I remember you that's
not it doesn't go am are you serious no
and Here I am bringing that up again
with the trophy that you've bought
you've lifted before still sitting in
between us you think that would be the
thing people yeah
one would think in fact I appreciate
your intro where they said you know
former Super Bowl winning head cook
because now more and more you don't
realize you know I've been doing this
for about 12 years now yes
meaning that Network thing and I did
games for Fox and of course with the
network yet working with you and and
people people will you know more and
more I'm introduced as a network analyst
which I'm cool with that's fine although
I was I wasn't here but someone case I'm
fan came up said didn't you used to be
Brian Billick what does that mean
like you you used to be somebody but now
you're just some slappy here and you're
just a European slap just like everybody
else in Europe you know I've been
quoting you many times in recent days
because this is one of my favorite lines
when and I'll set you up on it whenever
people say Bill Belichick is going to
take away the one thing you do best and
then you say oh compared to the rest of
us that obviously covered the decoys it
never occurred to us and the other
coaches that know we're gonna take away
what you did best but but you got to
give bill credit his his you know cuz
obviously I've always said we ought to
change this to the New England Patriot
Invitational they're here so often and
and you look at it and coaches you know
what what it truly is the difference
here listening to you and Steve talking
about because obviously Bill Belichick
is is maybe the greatest coach has ever
lived have been brilliant and the rest
of us do try you know and you kind of
look at well what are they doing that
maybe we can do but that that laser
focus that attention detail and it goes
part and parcel to that that you know
it's easier to make that second million
in the first million right so once
you've got that going and you then have
the latitude to build on that and do
those types of things so there's a lot
of things that that he and the
organization can do that it would be
tougher to do as another coach and
another circumstance until you build up
the street cred so to speak to be able
to take these these steps that they do
and get the players to come play but
there's no denying although I don't
maybe I'd be interested in seeing what
you think yep and just watching I came
in yesterday and watching the whole
media thing that they do they seem much
more relaxed I'll tell you the one
because the one thing I try not to do in
the 16 now Super Bowls that I've covered
is to say to try and glean know Sunday's
result from the demeanor behind a
microphone because of two things one is
I've seen I've seen no they look relaxed
and then they get curb-stomped uh and I
also don't want it to seem like we in
the media are such a crucial factor in
how things play out I don't ever want to
because you know the whole concept of
Super Bowl distraction we're always
talking about it
the media because that in a way does
Jennifer yes you're listening to us and
we're talking about it so we're part of
the distraction even though the
distraction may not be a distraction
we're talking about it until you admit
damn straight you're going to admit it's
a distraction because otherwise what are
we doing talking about distract that's
right so it's like trying to figure out
the outcome on and based on pregame
warmup I gave that up real early there's
times I'm thinking boy we're gonna kick
it and we just got the dog or it was
like god I'm really poor dropping balls
and then we come out and have a great
game so it's kind of that said as the
set up seeing Brady he's kind of like
now taking it in like well like they're
kind of like you know the old town
tuffet it they've gosh darn it
you know been here now nine times as a
tandem and obviously the Patriots a
tenth time you include the time with
Bella check I mean as a defensive
coordinator for Parcells with blood so
you know that I think they're taking it
in like it's their first and I'm worried
that means something significant you
know and and and would never in any way
intimated that their focus isn't going
to be their work ethic that we know them
to have but but part of it may be that
one they're playing on house money
Belichick and brave because it's like
I'm the last couple times they've been
here we well what does this mean for the
legacy well what we've we've zoomed so
far past that I mean I'd why wait for
the five years just just give him the
gold jacket now but I mean why wait for
five years after they retire but bill
what's Bill 67-68 Chris I think he's
around the same age you know right in
terms of courtiers yes so I don't think
I don't think it's unrealistic to
recognize there's someone who's gone
through that progression a little bit is
that they're at that stage and their
life were they they may not be there but
they can see it from here and they do
recognize and they've got such a legacy
that there's absolutely nothing can
happen this game that can tarnish that
legacy you're kind of playing with house
money that gives you a comfort zone to
relax in a way that
probably a good thing what's it what's
the 66 twice as old as Macbeth that's
justice all this big thing it's
unbelievable so let's get into the X's
and O's here buddy what it obviously
it's every single snap is different and
that's why Belichick as that
laser-focused to try and prepare for the
variables and control them in real time
best he can do what what do you think is
going to be the key proceed well so you
thought about it and in the show that
showing your half Sean O'Haire here on
he's my buddy on playbook which I really
enjoyed doing for the network cuz it
really is X's and O's yep it drives him
back into the film I have it for a long
time like I have now for playbook we're
on Mondays and Tuesdays I mean I get
every game I've got on the computer that
I see sideline endzone and so it kind of
draws me back into all of the games that
I can look at and say well what's making
the difference here and when you go back
and look at the tape the way I have the
matchup la matches up very very well
across the board in virtually every
aspect that if you want to look at it
just from a technical standpoint from an
Exynos standpoint you can see the
matchups a boy allies got a chance here
l he's got a chance here whether whether
it's the defensive line in that interior
with with su and Donald the backend I
think can match up in a different way
than they did with Kansas City not like
anybody can match up with tarik Hill but
I think the talents of Peters and Thule
match up pretty good with the style of
the passing game that the Brady has
offensively what they can do their
ability to run the ball I think we're
gonna see a good solid run effort not
only from CJ Anderson but Girly's pretty
good and and particularly out of the
backfield as well so everything matches
up but because of what we just talked
about earlier I mean I grew up in LA
I've grew up a Rams fan and I can sit
here and give you a dozen reasons why my
Rams you know I've got a lot of good
friends that John fossil coach for me in
Baltimore he's I think the best special
teams coach in the league and could make
the difference that's a very good
matchup sir Jed fish is on there as well
was with me in Baltimore so I got a lot
of reason to pull for for the Rams and I
am and and they're gonna win but if yes
but if you want me to put money on it no
I'm going with the Patriots and no cuz
I'm tired of getting beat up and every
time I go I find a reason not to go with
Brady and Belichick it cost you every
time well I mean the way you talked
about being from Los Angeles and rooting
for the Rams you sound like a referee
from the NFC champion of this conspiracy
theory I am NOT I think it's one of the
most ridiculous things I've ever heard
honestly you may get called in on the
lawsuit they could think you know no no
no I thought that was just it and then
there's folks who are saying well it's
just it I'm not saying that the referees
blew the call because they're from
Mission Viejo seventy miles away from
the Los Angeles Kyle I'm not saying that
I'm just saying it's a bad look well
then what is the bad look if you're not
saying that they were on the take
because they love LA
you know they're they love the Randy
Newman song you know I mean so so I mean
so what what are you saying but so we're
gonna sit down officials because of
where they're from because it's a bad
look even though I'm not saying the bad
look actually is something that is bad
there other than just a look I mean this
makes no sense
when I was doing games for Fox which I
really really enjoyed and and getting to
win every Friday and sitting and
watching practice and visiting with
coaches and players and you know as a
former coach I'm done coaching but if I
were to go back I would be a better
coach just for that experience because
you're sitting you imagine sitting in
your competition's boardroom mmm and to
watch how they practice and the
strategies it was a fascinating
experience but there were a couple times
well I remember sitting and and and and
we were visiting with the PR guy and
practice was going on and we were in a
room that overlooked the practice field
he gets up and he shuts the blinds and
it's like no you so so like you're
saying so what are you saying he said
I'm gonna call the opposing coach and
you know he doesn't need me to tell him
this is what you're going to do he's
prepared all week but there there was
some some places where it was kind of
like yeah we'd prefer for you
to watch Pratt and so so you're
intimating that that I might be that
unprofessional which I got it it was
cool but it was yeah so exactly what do
you say what are you saying if you're
not saying you're just saying that's the
21st century phrase I'm just saying
which is our caveat for saying exactly
the opposite yeah you for you're saying
I'm just saying it's like really they
say everything before the word but is BS
that's the reason but well okay so
what'd you do spent the last 20 minutes
saying obviously you don't believe all
due respect exactly
tell me about SeatGeek here Brian what
so what yeah one of the things I really
enjoyed been working with Sikhi for a
long time and they've got millions and
tickets whatever your ticket needs are
the thing I like you need to go even if
you're not in the market for tickets go
to the SeatGeek app because if you are
obviously it's place to go cuz they got
all the analytics they tell you what the
pricing is what's a good deal and what's
a bad deal you know I don't mind
overpaying for a good ticket I just
don't want to overpay for a bad ticket I
remember legendary Art Rooney always
used to say I don't mind over playing
for a good player I just don't want to
overplay for a bad player but you go and
use the SeatGeek app and particularly
now during the Super Bowl if you're in
the market for tickets you know it's all
about the timing right it early late
when can I get the ticket right average
resale price is about fifty eight
hundred right now and so it's yeah it's
you need to be the informed consumer
it's kind of fun to watch as I will all
week people looking for tickets and up
and down and the key now if you're if
you're a patriot fan you want a ticket
go buy a ticket over on the ramp side
because they're tracking lower right now
at a price you can get a better ticket
price so go to see geek comm put in the
Superbowl 300 promo code you're gonna
when was the last time anybody got your
money back right I'm a full-service guy
$300 off Super Bowl tickets by entering
SB 300 you can stay informed but see
geek.com Super Bowl ticket rack tracker
Brockman you'd have no problem being a
New England fan sitting amongst Los
Angelenos for long under bucks you know
Los Angeles you know they're very
sensitive we're nice people like I don't
know if we want to sit with New England
family what if I have to cheer New
England you don't have that problem yeah
I'm from LA I know for a fact that if it
turns bad enough you could whip on that
New England Patriot happen with
I'm hitting my own people here cuz I'm
from LA no hey you're allowed to do I
gotta be honest with you when the Rams
got drew the Cowboys as they're a home
game in the divisional round I'm like oh
because the Cowboys friends are gonna
take up half the stadium and and that
was not the case great right no I was
surprised at the number of elephants
they exist I'm not saying I'm not saying
they're frontrunner I'm just saying I'm
just saying coach Bill ik on Twitter
he's a great follow I follow him check
him out on the NFL Network he's part of
the eight and a half hour edition of NFL
gameday morning
starting at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time on
Super Sunday that I am proud to be
hosting from from minute one to minute
last good to see a Brian Billick the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience